I'm speaking today with coronal the
president of the ftth Council in Europe
currently or the president but sadly the
retiring president tell us about the
last three years when you've been in
that capacity what for you have been
some of the highlights the highlights
has that not have been that we are more
accepted as an organization today we are
one of the most established
organizations in Brussels speaking to
their policy community I think that is a
very important step for us to take
during these years also national levels
and all the investor days and the local
events that we arrange to have more like
multi stakeholder meetings if you can
call them that I think that is what we
do best today actually yeah now the show
here is the 12th conference it seems to
getting more and more significant on the
European landscape it's been another
great show has there yeah it has
definitely been yeah I I think it's also
proves that their conference itself is
more important than the location we
often talk a lot about where to put the
conference where to go next but it
doesn't really matter where we go the
people show up once again we have three
thousand delegates that is a lot and
also sponsors and the speakers from all
across Europe and the world that is
great yes now you're going to say going
to a sort of retirement in terms of this
capacity what would you like to see the
you know the council go into what so the
way would you like to see it develop in
the future yeah well as a member of the
Council not the president anymore i
would like to see them focus continue to
focus on the activities in brussels and
on a national level because we have a
really important role to discuss a new
policy frameworks a new regulatory
frameworks and the investments so i
would like them to continue the work
that we just started we're just
scratching the surface so they need to
continue and be patient and what about
yourself what what will you be doing now
in the future what are your plans my
plans for the future I'm going back to
my company they just borrowed me for a
while to the council's I'm going back
there to rolla and do markets and sales
in Sweden definitely and talking to
investors and local utilities and the
broadband networks based purely on fiber
what courage been great
talk to you and many congratulations on
the three years in your time as
president thank you so a nice
conversation there with Coronel who is
going to a sort of retirement but we can
guess you'll be very very busy in Sweden